i've been dreaming about this in my  whole life  and the giant's gold it's the biggest  treasure that's never been found five  billion easy  so when do we start yeah put that in  your head  hello hello  i can hear you i'm sitting right  next your brother believed that there  was a final piece  well you know my brother sam what else  aren't you telling me  you have no idea who you partnered  it's with take a little longer than i  thought kids  i assume we're 50 50 right  50 50. you get 10 that's me being  generous wow  let's play some parachutes what  unless you know a better way to jump on  it  oh my god i'm so sorry  [Applause]  come on  500 years ago my family found the  vulture and was betrayed  so much blood  you're doing great  this ain't over  hey you still with me  barely  what's with the cat she's just for you  what the life seems super sad i'm not  gonna keep this thing exclusively at  cinemas  you